[Musik]
herzig und die leute heute wieder mit
witz und deswegen bewerten heute ist
nick youtuber diese super info
und das wird noch halb verrückt machen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dort findet auch mit von jedem zusammen
mit oliver zeiten freundin von dem
vorfall die freundin von dem geht hier
gar nicht gezeigt habe auf jeden fall
diese person passen wir zusammen
klar die löwen war auch hatte ich mir
diesmal schließen wird ist aber okay
okay okay okay okay hier
[Musik]
die bundeskasse angela merkel über fünf
jahre und dort kgb okay vielleicht
kennst du glücklich aus lecks wirklich
die leute sind wir meister sagte dazu
wichtig haben oder zeugen als 2000
befragten richtig gefeiert
dann haben wir hier einen weiteren
youtuber den kennst du wahrscheinlich
hinterher nicht überzeugen kann aber
sagen dass wir so wirkt diese person
[Musik]
doch von menschen nämlich abschnitten
herausgesucht dass es halt wirklich
schon hab mir lange überlegt und weil du
bist die jugendschützer gegen überauchen
[Musik]
einer clearing auch wie viel blödheit
und youtube amerika geschlagen
kein problem für sexistische weiter die
jugend ihren persönlichen freundes video
hier könne man gerade bei ihren neuen
folge von erwartet dass die von
minecraft 1 media check auf jeden fall
solche leute machen bis zum nächsten mal